من هذه الانتقادات اللطيفة
للقرويين الكسالى والنظافة في المساحات الخضراء
من منطقة هيريزون
، يتم سحب بعض أبشع جرائم هذه
الحرب إلى النور ،
فهذه داشا تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
وكانت حاملاً في شهرها السادس عندما
جاءت القوات الروسية قبل أكثر من شهر بقليل.
قريتها هنا
كانت عائلتها في الطابق السفلي
تحتمي من البرد والقنابل
والروس يطلقون النار في الهواء أو على
السيارات والأرجل ، قالت
عند الغسق إنهم أحضروا الأطفال
إلى المطبخ لتناول الطعام حيث كان هناك
جنديان ، أحدهما في حالة سكر
حتى
أمه.  ثم جاءت زميلة رصينة
وأخبرت المهاجم المخمور أن يتوقف دون
جدوى
بحلول ذلك الوقت سقطت الليلة في
المنزل البارد ، وسمعت الروس يقولون
إن اسم مهاجمها كان أزرقًا وكان من
دونيتسك وكان لديه ماضٍ إجرامي
حاول مهاجمتها مرة أخرى.  قالت
حتى جاء القناصة الروس في وقت لاحق
لمساعدتها ولكن لا يزال بعض الجنود الروس
في تلك الوحدة يشعرون
بالاشمئزاز مما حدث وحاولوا
نقلها
هي وجزء من عائلتها.  ay إلى
الأمان ثم بدأت عملية
بدا فيها الجنود الروس وكأنهم يحاولون
إقناعها بالعودة إلى الادعاءات التي قدمتها
بعد يومين ، تم نقلها إلى
قائد مظلي روسي قالت
إنه بدأ بالصراخ عليها كما
فعل مهاجمها.
لا لأنني لا يجب أن أضعها في مقطع فيديو
، يبدو أنهم صدقوها ولكن
مصير مغتصبها لا يزال غير واضح
بينما لا يمكننا التحقق بشكل مستقل من
قصتها المروعة أخبرنا المدعون الأوكرانيون
أنهم حققوا في
القضية وأكدوا هذا الاعتداء الذي قاموا به.
قال إنها جريمة حرب
ولكن مثل الكثير هنا ، السؤال لماذا
هو الشخص الذي لا يجيب على إجابة إنسانية
أكثر من
[موسيقى]
هناك حياة هنا يمكنك أن ترى أن
روسيا قد تغيرت إلى الأبد ولكن أيضًا
أولئك الذين تجلس صدمتهم تحت
السطح ويعيشون
نيك بايتون حروب سي ان ان منطقة هداسون
اوكرانيا